[Aplausos]
ningún presidente estadounidense escapa
al ejercicio y Esta es una nueva
oportunidad para Joe biden pronunciar el
discurso sobre el estado de la unión en
el congreso preparado estos últimos días
lejos del Capitolio pero con rigor según
estas fotos publicadas en la cuenta
oficial del presidente de Estados Unidos
rodeado de sus asesores más cercanos
está trabajando ningún detalle parece
dejarse al azar Incluso el ajuste del
apuntador Joe biden está decidido a
convencer a unos Estados Unidos
desilusionado según los resultados de un
sondeo de opinión realizado por el
Washington post y ABC el 62% de los
estadounidenses cree que su presidente
no ha hecho mucho Incluso poco o nada
desde enero de 2021 la misma encuesta
revela que el 38% de los votantes
demócratas de su bando quieren otro
candidato para 2024
sin embargo la economía estadounidense
va bastante bien A pesar de la inflación
el crecimiento es Sólido y el desempleo
está en su nivel más bajo Con solo un
3,5 si Joe biden destaca estos grandes
avances no podrá elogiar otras dos
reformas en las que se esperaba que se
centrara aumentar el techo de la deuda y
la reforma policial más que nunca tras
el asesinato del joven afroamericano
tyre Nichols en materia de política
exterior el inquilino de la Casa Blanca
debería recordar su apoyo a Ucrania y
reposicionarse como líder del mundo
libre tal y como hizo hace un año es
otra oportunidad para elogiar parte de
su trayectoria antes de que se le
recuerde otro tema de tensión su
relación con Beijing el bando
republicano pretende atacarle por este
asunto el del globo chino la oposición
acusa al presidente de falta de firmeza
ante el que consideran un gran rival en
cuanto a una posible candidatura para
2024 el presidente biden podría
aprovechar el discurso ante el congreso
para anunciarla oficialmente